[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quelqu'un a compris ce qui vient d'être
exposé
et bien ce n'est pas normal ce ne sont
pas des mots
je suis là pour que mes peurs mais aussi
pour que mon cri d'espoir soit entendu
un chien éduqué
on ne peut évoquer l'éducation de l'être
humain son nécessairement évoquer ce
cumul d'information et de connaissances
qui étaient construit au fil des siècles
on y repensant la transmission de ce
cumule d'informations et de
connaissances n'aurait jamais pu être
possible
stable et continue sans ces facteurs
formidables que sont les langues et plus
particulièrement les crimes
or lorsque nous parlons d'écriture et de
langue nous parlons essentiellement de
communication
et quand nous parlons de communication
nous parlons d'humanité je vous explique
pourquoi
en effet les langues et les cris font
partie des caractéristiques majeures qui
nous différencient de l'espèce animale
en reconsidérant cette différence nous
pouvons nous rendre compte à quel point
ces facultés sont considérables et
importantes
mais plus important encore
avons-nous conscience de leur impact sur
la société
il est clair que les langues et les cris
ont entre autres fonder ce cumul
d'informations et de connaissances qui a
conduit l'homme à des progrès et
découvertes incroyables
cependant quand on y regarde de plus
près pour essayer de voir dans quel
domaine ces progrès ont été réalisés on
se rend compte qu'ils sont
principalement orientés sur les
découvertes scientifiques dans
différents domaines comme la médecine
l'ingénierie l'astronomie l'informatique
ainsi que dans certaines sciences
humaines la psychologie les sciences
sociales la philosophie et aussi
l'essence naturelle
mais ce progrès qui aurait pu conduire
l'homme à un futur oui il aurait la vie
et l'avenir dont il rêve depuis
longtemps ne semble pas suffisant pour
nous y conduire
ma question est la suivante
ces moyens de communication si important
sont-ils utilisés correctement
alors juste valeur pour des causes
réellement pertinentes
moi à 14 ans je n'arrive pas à me
projeter dans ma vie d'adulte d'une
façon paisible et rassurante
moi à 14 ans j'ai peur de l'avenir et
pour l'avenir j'ai peur pour ma
génération et de ma génération
quel avenir au Rama génération et
qu'elle va venir ma génération pourra se
construire
grandir dans un environnement où les
jeunes voient constamment autour d'eux
leurs aînés utilisaient les moyens de
communication pour faire du tort aux
autres ne peut que les tromper et les
induire dans ce mensonge où l'on
normalise de tels comportements malsain
et petit à petit à force de vivre ce
mensonge il devient vérité et fait de
notre réalité
un cumul de ces comportements devenu
normalisé
alors l'avenir ne pourra que dériver
cette dérive qui s'intensifie petit à
petit me laisse sans voix mis à part
dans le domaine des sciences et des
sciences humaines l'homme a-t-il
véritablement utiliser les langues et la
communication pour se construire un
monde meilleur
les compétitions malsaines les conflits
et les guerres ont-ils disparu
la famine
l'analphabétisme mais les inégalités
ont-ils été éradiqué
n'est-il pas temps de repenser toute
notre façon d'être et de vivre n'est-il
pas tant que l'être humain se
ressaisisse
le paradoxe et même l'ironie de notre
époque et que l'être humain n'a jamais
eu autant de moyens de communication
performants sophistiqué et rapide
cependant il n'a peut-être jamais aussi
mal ou aussi superficiellement
communiquer
vous pensez que si vous aviez vu ça il y
a 15 ou 20 ans vous aurez compris
quelque chose
c'est peut-être cette vitesse
mais aussi cette facilité dans
lesquelles nous sommes enfermés qui font
que nous survolons plus que nous la
profonde et
que nous bafouillons puisque nous
n'exprimons que nous parcourons plus que
nous n'étudions les sujets et les
questions pour lesquelles nous sommes
sollicités
sans en faire une généralité mais en
regardant de plus près les messages et
les textes que nous échangeons sur les
réseaux ou les plateformes de messagerie
nous nous rendons compte très
cruellement de la qualité dégradée de
ces échanges tant au niveau de la langue
du contenu et de la forme
les textos d'aujourd'hui deviennent des
symboles des abréviations des
onomatopées
sommes-nous en train de régresser au
point de au point de rejoindre les
langues et l'écriture des premiers
hommes où sommes-nous en train
d'inventer un langage plus simple plus
universel
toutefois il me semble prudent de dire
qu'avec ce genre de crier de langue nous
sommes en train de perdre graduellement
et inévitablement notre capacité à nous
exprimer correctement et avec elle toute
la richesse et la variété qu'une langue
peut offrir
peut-être que dans les anciens temps les
hommes n'arrivaient pas à communiquer
faute de moyens adéquats
mais aujourd'hui nous n'avons plus cette
excuse et ne tient qu'à nous de le faire
correctement
si l'écriture et l'événement qui sépare
l'histoire de la préhistoire et que
l'histoire ne commence à réellement que
le jour où l'on pu l'écrire alors notre
langue est-elle en train de s'appauvrir
ou au contraire sommes-nous en train de
préparer une nouvelle ère qui serait
peut-être la Poste histoire
mieux écrire mieux parler mieux
s'exprimer est une force est une façon
de témoigner du respect de chacun de
nous envers l'autre
et le respect de l'autre n'est-il pas la
véritable clé du salut
peut-être que c'est simple geste de
respect entre nous et de respect des
langues permettront de sauver l'homme de
corriger une trajectoire si inquiétante
lorsque je parle de failles pareil dans
notre société je ne commence pas à
lancer un appel de secours aux grandes
organisations et mouvements mais à
chacun d'entre nous
je suis là essentiellement pour parler
des petites choses celles que nous
faisons au quotidien
notre façon de parler à nos frères et
soeurs celle de nos interactions sur les
réseaux sociaux comment se comporter
avec les autres la liste longue
c'est vrai qu'un changement haute
échelle sera très dur à effectuer mais
ensemble petit à petit en cumulant nos
efforts nous arriverons certainement à
aboutir un changement
Simon Faya dit
on peut si on veut ramener tout l'art de
vivre à un bon usage du langage
moi à 14 ans j'ai grand espoir dans
l'avenir de l'homme s'il réussit à le
façonner comme il se doit
moi à 14 ans je vous invite tous à être
les acteurs de cette correction de
trajectoire dans l'histoire de
l'humanité
pour que ceux qui comme moi à 14 ans
déjà craignent l'avenir cesse d'avoir
peur merci
[Applaudissements]